as women start earning more merit
satisfaction goes down for men and for
women as women move up the corporate
ladder they're more likely to become
divorced but that's not true for men if
women win political office they're more
likely to get divorced than the women
counterparts who lost their political
office the more women gain status the
more discord happens in their marriage
[Music]
did you see the serena williams article
in vogue
i did not
oh well let me tell you about it so
her issue
the the article is about the fact she's
now 41. she's still a top flight tennis
player
and she's got one child i think olympia
and
is now was aware that she would have a
limited window perhaps to have more
children uh so he's having to leave the
sport she had some complications
medically after the last child um
perhaps slightly brought on by being an
elite athlete i don't know the sort of
stresses that that puts your body under
the kind of internal changes or external
changes um and then there's a couple of
sections here so believe me i never
wanted to have to choose between tennis
and the family she wrote i don't think
it's fair if i were a guy i wouldn't be
writing this because i'd be out there
playing and winning while my wife was
doing the physical labor of expanding
our family i have to presume that she
means the literal physical labor of
expanding the family maybe i'd be more
of a tom brady if i had that opportunity
williams wrote pointing that the
football legend brady45 who has three
children and played in the nfl for 22
seasons before announcing his retirement
in february before changing his mind and
announcing that he would return for a
23rd season just one month later ahead
of her 41st birthday williams realized
he had an hour window to get pregnant
again i definitely don't want to be
pregnant again as an athlete she said
these days if i have to choose between
building my tennis resume and building a
family i choose the latter i thought
that was very interesting yeah that is
interesting
especially since i think tom brady's um
on retirement is causing discord in his
own marriage from you know at least what
the gossip is right
uh but you know there's something to
that women do often have to make a
trade-off that men
you know typically don't
have to this is kind of a new thing with
you know women being able to
you know have be the serena williams of
the world or you know um the
uh i'm
blanking on a name of you know ceo of
company um and we kind of have to figure
out like what are we going to excel at
are we going to excel at our careers are
we going to excel
as a parent because it's really hard to
do both
very well at the same time
um and so
you know historically
that has sort of been the the contract
that we used to enter into through
marriage is you know the the the male
works and the female stays at home and
runs the household which is a lot of
work
and
what
i find really interesting is now that
women have made tremendous strides into
the workplace
they're finding themselves no better off
in terms of
households
you know running of the household and
things that they have to do to make you
know the household run all of that
unpaid labor isn't going away it's it's
still there
and what we find through the research is
that women who working women actually do
more housework than women who
are stay-at-home moms
what's the statistics behind that how
does that work
well we just sort of get them to report
how many hours a day they spend on
various you know things or activities
around the house and what i think is
happening is that women working women
feel more guilt surrounding you know not
doing what's typically
you know thought of as you know helping
around the house and um
and
you know
they're actually doing more
uh and more housework than you know that
was done even in the even in the 60s now
that has a lot to do with kids too
because kids require a lot of uh
parental involvement now than
i think was happening you know certainly
in the 50s and 60s with scheduling and
all that kind of stuff
what's scheduling
uh well now there's more parent
involvement and you know even play dates
you got to call up the other parent you
got to figure out you know who's
volunteering for this and and that and
the other thing and i think there's you
know when kids are involved in so many
extracurricular activities
rather than just letting them to go play
stickball out in the street oh okay
you know so yeah so this is perhaps a
byproduct not of helicopter parenting
but of a an overly observant parental
style yeah i think so and i think i
think that part of it is you know
helicopter parenting um
that we're doing now uh more than we
ever had before you know we just kind of
you know let our kids run around uh
and that's a whole other topic i guess
to talk about is you know how we manage
our kids lives now in a way that we
never had
you know before
going back to what you said at the very
beginning it's uh a novel situation that
we found ourselves in where women can
have the choice between being a carer or
having a career yeah and i think it's
the uk statistics say that more women
are childless at 30 than not now in the
uk so 50.1 percent of women by 30 do not
have children so they are in the the
bigger age bracket i also saw joyce
benninson's newest paper
quotes just offhand half of all women in
the world are married by 18.
half
half of all women in the world are
married by the age of 18.
wow
that blew my mind
those two statistics side by side
absolutely took my head off
so
so some of those women
are waiting that long no so what i think
it is is that um the childless at 30
50.1 percent is exclusively i want to
say to the uk i think it's the uk
there's definitely one in wales
my point being that even
uh this is novel
ancestrally the choice between the two
and it is very much a weird
um
phenomenon as well western educated
industrialized blah blah it's very much
over our side but
on average half of all women in the
world are married by 18 evidently skewed
by probably a lot of africa or a lot of
india some continental stuff so that
doesn't shock me as much but i'd be
interested to know like for the united
states or other western countries it's
got to be much oh way later way way way
later yeah yeah yeah
right i mean that's that's that's a
mismatch you know ancestrally from you
know what usually happens in terms of
mating
it's so interesting because usually
there's this critical period when kids
hit puberty and they become really
interested and that's where like
intersectional competition comes in and
this is where you know and girls hit it
before boys hit it and you get a sense
of where do you sort of land on the
mating market and
it kind of solidifies so if you if you
are a big nerd in high school you never
lose that nerdiness i know because
that's me i never lose it in my mind i'm
you know a nerd
and so that's when you know you're
supposed to be figuring out you know
where you're going to go and that's when
all of the great magic happened in terms
of in terms of mating you know
ancestrally and now we have this period
where you know we're
you know we just keep keep dating and
keep dating and keep dating and keep
dating
and you know and and you know
reproducing or not and certainly a lot
of women delay it i mean serena williams
is
a geriatric mother you know in terms of
you know in today's terms too but a lot
but she's not unlike a lot of women
um who are delaying it there's you know
women do have a lot more options now
even though that trade-off
still haunts us because you know we can
move up that corporate ladder but
as women move up the corporate ladder
that doesn't open up a whole new sea of
men who are going to come home and shore
up all of the duties on the home front
you know whereas the reverse is true
for men so women kind of find themselves
in this you know in this dilemma
where they're contributing a lot at home
financially and they're contributing a
lot at home
with unpaid labor and that could be just
because women don't want to relinquish
you know some of the things to men men
also tend to do more
i guess what's a good word for it manly
type of household labor like mowing the
lawn or you know fixing things as
opposed to laundry and all the other
stuff that has to get done
um and so
you know this can now within marriages
cause a lot of
unpaid labor disputes that were never
around before and discord
and resentment and all that kind of
stuff that that bubbles up did you look
at the fact that
women who women deny the fact that
they're the primary breadwinner even
when they are one
yes so
in a survey of
married couples where
all of them were involved in a situation
where the women was the breadwinner
over 60 said that that was not true
so
so in a survey where
we know this about people people want to
report in a socially desirable way
so that's a problem in most you know
experiments that use surveys
but it was interesting because they were
pre-selected
a sample
of individuals where researchers knew
that these were you know couples where
the women the woman was the breadwinner
and they didn't want to report it that
that was actually the case so over 60
said that they were not that it was the
man or that they were equal
well culturally at the moment are we not
seeing a lot of female empowerment you
can have it all be a boss [ __ ] clap
back you know compete with the men more
women two to one female to males
completing four-year us college degrees
by 20-30 1 111 pounds more earned by
women between the ages of 21 and 29 in
the uk like i
it seems surprising to me that women
would under-report the fact that they
are the primary breadwinners when
culturally at least
what the media perhaps says this isn't
necessarily emergent bottom-up this
isn't what's happening in terms of norms
but there's there does seem to be a
pretty big push for women to become more
masculinized in that way
yeah i mean i guess it's so so that's
the haunting of sort of the traditional
norms that still are not even though
there is a lot of movement towards you
know uh women female empowerment it's
just it's really hard to give so
uh
so a lot of women still
want a partner who is at you know sort
of at their own level so making as much
as them or
more
um and
you know they want a counterpart and so
i could see where you know that still so
so the reflection of women not wanting
to say yeah i'm the breadwinner
like it is
it is the haunting of that you know sort
of traditional values that we used to
have like there
they've been around for so long
where we had this uh system of you know
women having this obligatory investment
in children
and men going off to do
other things
i mean you know women couldn't go off to
war because then children would die and
so would the you know any genes that
supported a penchant for waging war in
women
men were free to go do that because they
weren't having the babies and
you know and and that's something that
we do know that was happening women were
having the babies men were not having
the babies and so
you know
all of our you know female ancestors
going you know back in time now this is
before birth control and so we still you
know so if you were a woman
and you were sexually active you were
probably a mother most certainly
um
and so
we didn't have the the luxuries of you
know outsourcing any care
for most of human existence so all of
the stuff that's happening in our modern
world now is really new and our brains
just haven't caught up so we have a part
of our brain that can say you know women
empowerment and that's kind of you know
we we kind of have to you know push the
social norms forward and then you know
we learn what we're valued and make and
it can cause change but you know this is
the the part of our brain that can think
about this stuff intellectually is
scaffolded onto you know deeper brain
systems that have just been around for
you know millions of years and it's a
hard override sometimes
do careers make women happy
yes
so i would say it also depends on the
career i would say it depends on the job
um
i think that you know women face more
of that mating parent not mating
parenting but like sort of status
driving parenting conflict
um you know they the career family
trade-off conflict i think that women
experience it more
than men
do uh but
but when women are able to you know take
time for themselves and and pursue what
they're passionate about that increases
their overall well-being
um
but
you know women experience a lot of
burnout women experience a lot of stress
because there are these you know demands
on them
you know someone needs to someone needs
to give birth to the child right someone
needs to do that
the the bit that kind of got me a little
bit about serena's
um discussion there the bit of left a
bit of a bad taste in my mouth was when
she said about labor
doing the physical labor it's like look
like men can't get pregnant that's that
is an issue that we have i understand
that there are some disparities men
think about sex more than women should
we say that the fact that women don't
think about sex as much as men do is an
imbalance that needs to be corrected so
that men can be made more happy in the
world i i don't know my point being that
especially for the first couple of years
i i don't have kids but i'm around
some friends that do and the dad is a
spare part for the first two years the
mother is the one that that has more of
an innate sense about what the child
needs the mother is the one that the
child seems to pine for a lot more
they're the ones that have a better bond
they're the ones that are able to deal
with crying and nappy changes and and
care and to have this intuition that is
that is an imbalance between the
capacities of men in the capacities of
women
i mean serena's worth several hundred
million dollars i'm sure that she can
find a perfectly
uh successful team of nannies that could
come in and take over but the fact that
she might feel guilt around doing that
isn't something i think that's been laid
at her feet from like vestigial
evolutionary
oppression or some sort of ruling of of
pressure from men i think that it is a
byproduct of the fact that the
way that we create babies
is asymmetric with regards to what men
and women do in terms of their
investment
yeah i think so too so you're saying
it's not an evolutionary vestige but you
know the biological
you know reality what they are yeah
and so you mean and serena you know so
so it so all of these things putting so
much burden on women and there's so many
women who are just like burnt out
because of this trade-off but women of
means do have the ability to outsource
this even at the level of outsourcing
uh you know through surrogacy who has
the baby
a lot of women are doing this now right
so is that what rich is that what rich
women do
i think so
don't they i don't know that's part of
that's part of it so she could do that
if she wanted to do it but
you know
she's already a mother
and for many women you know once that
switch gets turned on there's so much
biology that comes online that was never
online before that has to do with an
increase in nurturing and wanting to
care for children so there's a
caregiving mismatch between men and
women and not mismatched but maybe
that's the wrong word
but it's just
yeah an imbalance so you know
moms are just more nurturing than dads
and a lot of that has to do with once
you have a baby
boy do these hormones you know the
hormones are basically the puppeteers of
our behavior and once you have a baby
uh we have this whole suite of hormones
that come online and you know direct our
mothering behavior we see it across all
other species i mean for those of you
who have seen you know animals become
mothers you could see you know a female
who you know was
you know aggressive and taking huge
risks then she has a baby and and she
might take risks to that baby but
you know she all of a sudden becomes
like the most caring and nurturing
you know
mama bear and and and so men don't ever
have i mean certainly things happen and
there has been research showing that you
know when men become fathers their
hormonal profile
changes too but not to the level
of what happens for for women with
prolactin and oxytocin and um that sort
of direct that
you know that that caregiving and i
don't know how much that goes
away because we still have you know even
after you have kids and they grow up
you're becoming a grandmother i mean
that whole process where women can no
longer reproduce
and the leading theory is that you know
then
you're no longer reproducing because
your daughters are starting to reproduce
and you cannot help her if you are the
hypothesis yeah the grandmother
hypothesis
and so
so
i don't know that there was huge
selection pressure for women to ever you
know lose that once
they became mothers
go one step behind that is there a
natural impulse for women to want to
have children at all
that is a really
great question and
uh
so
yeah just to clarify the question
obviously the the point is women could
want to have sex and a byproduct of
having sex would be having children like
what we talked about here is that once
you have a child there is a maternal
cascade
that gets flicked on and is very
difficult perhaps to stop and not only
continues through child number one
potentially two three four and so on but
then also continues you into
grandmotherhood as well and all the rest
of it my
the point that i'm interested in is
prior to having the child is there an
impulse to have children
so
so yes and no
so here so women are complicated because
we have two hormones when we're
naturally cycling so
on birth control is a whole nother ball
of wax but
um so women have you know sex hormones
we have testosterone but the primary one
in women is um
i shouldn't say primary one because you
know we have we have a significant
amount of testosterone but but across
the cycle you know estrogen increases
and then it you know
dips down again and then progesterone
increases and we're preparing our body
every month for a pregnancy
and progesterone is more of a nurturing
hormone that will increase
progressively if the the woman becomes
pregnant within that cycle and so
you know what so i uh
used to do a lot of work looking at
women's changes in women's behavior
across the cycle and so
when looking at desire to have a child
even things like would you get an
abortion really heavy questions that you
know i tend to steer away from now
because they're such hot buttons but
what we find is that when women are
ovulating so this is a time when um you
know estrogen has just increased and
it's you know they're really interested
they're more their sexual desires
increased and what
dips down is all the parenting stuff so
they're not interested in children at
all
at all
when they're ovulating now
when
that's finished and their body is
preparing to potentially become pregnant
then
that interest creeps up a little bit so
so to answer your question um before
women have babies are they more
interested in having children than men i
bet you if we just randomly sampled we'd
find a sex difference there but because
women's pro women kind of cycle in and
out of you know high hormones that do
two different things one's mating and
sex one's parenting
um
that
you know it it
it kind of depends
so
yeah you're right like we don't need um
an interest in children to get them we
just need an interest in sex
but once women become pregnant that's
when
you know nature says all right
time to time to do the caregiving time
time to become more nurturing and want
to do the you know the nesting and we
set up for the baby we become interested
in watching um you know bringing home
baby and we wonder why our partners
aren't interested in it and they're not
reading all the books that we want them
to read because this is a big deal so
it's like then it's a complete
you know shift so would you say perhaps
that men and women diverge a lot more in
their
behavior and their predisposition upon
the point in which women get pregnant i
imagine that that must cause a little
bit of
um
friction in
in marriages especially where the
man and woman perhaps were very similar
for a long time and then there is this
big cascade of hormones that gets
released i've also heard that toward the
back end of pregnancy
that women can actually
feel more turned off or even partially
disgusted by the smell of their male
partner and they're more attracted to
the smell of their own kin so their
genetic lineage and this again is like
i'm very very close i'm to giving birth
i'm very very vulnerable i need to be
with someone that i know is no physical
threat to me uh there's also i mean you
know changes in hormones when girls go
on the pill versus come off the pill
there's apparently potential changes in
attraction toward mates that one of the
pieces of dating advice that i saw
floating around on the internet is
before you marry a woman get her to come
off the pill for six months to see if
she still likes you and
all of this stuff my point being like
it's fascinating the hormonal profile of
women is is absolutely fascinating and
it's fascinating in a way that men i
don't think are really ever going to
understand yeah
yeah i
i don't think so it is it is really
interesting and um you know so
um before so your original question was
do women want children um or something
like this and so
all of the stuff before they become a
mom i think a lot of that is
is the you know sort of social values
that we learn i mean it's kind of like
what you do
you know is you know get married and and
have a kid and you know
that's that's part of it too and part of
it probably is you know once a month we
have this kind of you know hormones that
come online that make us feel like i
should probably have a family
and then it's um
and then it's a week of you know having
higher sexual desire and then it's you
know i heard
i heard that the
behavior change across women's ovulatory
cycle has come under quite a lot of
firing criticism recently what's your
what's your thoughts on that i know
you've done a lot of work here
so i think the criticism criticism comes
from you know how do you
how do you
how are we calculating the cycle and how
are we estimating fertility because for
a long time that varied
it was almost like varied by researcher
and so
there was a lot of criticism about
having such flexibility
with how you calculate it means that you
can just sort of
figure out where your effect that you
want to show sits
in all of these different ways and maybe
one of them works and you can publish a
paper on it
so
there was a big push to come to a
consensus with how are we going to be
estimating fertility well
the best way is to really just go in and
measure day by day hormonal profiles and
you know as you you know clinically and
then figure that out as opposed to like
having a researcher estimate the cycles
and so forth um but you know any time so
there's a lot of stereotypes that
surround women and hormones
um women are hormonal women you know
don't make them cry they shouldn't you
know they shouldn't be you know holding
political office because maybe they're
going to be on their period and they're
cranky and this and the other and uh and
so because of those stereotypes it's
really difficult to study changes in
women's behavior across the cycle
because
you do get i've gotten personally a lot
of pushback uh on looking at behavioral
shifts uh related to
you know shifts in hormones on you know
on items that are issues that you know
are pretty sensitive
so like political preference and um oh
yeah didn't didn't you put something out
that cnn had a problem with to do with
obama and voting yeah tell us that yeah
so
so first of all
men's hormones influence all this stuff
look christine you don't need to give
another caveat right you're among
friends here okay
uh
yes and
you know that was
that was
i i should have been prepared for it i
wasn't prepared for the pushback so what
had happened with
that
is i started seeing little shifts in in
in my data in women's religiosity so
just general questions that we just had
as part of you know general surveys that
we would give women like how much do you
believe in god uh and then it would like
there would be a a dip at ovulation like
they believed less you know i'm like
that's so weird and that's kind of how
we started following up on it was
looking at uh women's religious views um
and they would loosen a little bit so
we're not talking like i'm a devout
catholic and then i'm ovulating and now
i'm an atheist these are just like tiny
shifts but we pick them up because it's
the same woman serving as her own
control throughout the cycle and that
has a lot of statistical power so even
if you just become you know if you're
answering on a scale one through nine
and you're at an eight you come down to
a seven that's going to pick up as
something something shifting inside of
you
and so
from there you know as a young scholar i
was like oh my god this is probably
having major implications for for even
political views especially the social
political views that have sort of like
um
you know the the the the
sort of sexual undertones to them like
wanting to control people's sexuality or
punish for different mating strategies
and stuff like that
and so that's where i took it into
looking at social political
orientation and finding that it was kind
of
similar
for single women at least in my data and
i thought well this is going to come
into play and it just happened that you
know obama was running against mitt
romney and they were both relatively
attractive men so i could it was kind of
like a control for that because they're
both tall and attractive
and uh and and i ran a survey and asked
these social political questions and
calculated the fertility it was a
cross-sectional so wherever a woman was
on the day that i did this huge survey
and i asked them to
who are they going to vote for
and
we found that when
single women were ovulating
versus when they were not this was they
were more likely to well they became a
lot more um
liberal and more likely to vote for
obama but the reverse was true for women
who were in committed relationships so
they became a bit more conservative and
when they were ovulating yeah when they
were ovulating and more likely to vote
for mitt romney so again ovulation
uh estrogen sex hormone that's high and
it's shifting these you know views and
so there must be some underlying sexual
strategy implication for what's
for what's going on what do you think
that is
well
it's like we really want our attitudes
and our behaviors to be as aligned as
possible so if our behavior is one thing
our attitude is we're gonna shift our
attitude to match it
so
um you know
for women in relationships so we know so
the answer is i don't really know for
sure but here's what i think is going on
um you're really interested in sex more
so at ovulation than any other time in
the month and so when you're thinking a
lot about sex it's really hard to also
think about
god for her for for many women
so you know so for single women it's a
little bit easier to understand because
you know they're free to think about sex
and
and have sex with the partner that they
can optimize mate choice with women
can't really optimize mate choice who
are in marriages unless that is their
you know partner uh and
um and they're tending to become more
conservative i think because that's
the relationship that they're in is a
mated relationship would there be
potentially something around
wanting to control other women's
uh sexual like intrasexual competition
for mates at this but i would have
thought that that would have been higher
among the women that hadn't yet found a
mate i thought that they would have
wanted to control the sexuality of other
women more when they don't have a mate
that's locked down than when they do
yeah
um
that's you know that's an interesting
question um one of the interpretations
we had for the women in relationships
was just that it's punishing promiscuous
women because you've you've kind of
have a a steady stream of resources
you've got a partner and
women who are single represent a threat
to that no so you're invested in the
market more
yeah and so i think that yeah so they're
like abortion yes same-sex marriage no i
mean even though so these things are
tangentially related to sexual
strategies even like drug use you know
so drug you know that they didn't want
you know marijuana to be legalized you
know these women in relationships so i
think it's trying to lock down the
threat
the the behavior to punish the behavior
of all those women out there who are
threats to
to to to what they have
um
now you know and but and and so yes
single women are you know are still
competitive but i think that
um you know they're on the hunt well
they've got less skin in the game right
yeah they've got less skin in the game
um because you know
you know if you lose a husband to one of
these uh women
um and
yeah i mean we didn't look at it it'd be
interesting to look at it even outside
of the cycle and i and and some somebody
might have
looked at this um
you know so you kind of just align
yourself with the values that are um
you know associated with your way of
life um
and
uh
and protecting that yeah you want the
world to give you more of what it is
that you've got at the moment or what
you think would it would enable you to
move forward with the strategy okay so
going back to the
um relative
uh career dynamics within
couples men and women
vincent haranam who you might be
familiar with he's been on the show
before he had some really interesting
statistics i just want to give you here
around
financial prospects and mate
desirability and stuff women valued good
financial prospects in a mate roughly
twice as much as men did this gender
difference has not changed in fact in a
2014 pew research survey reported that
78
of unmarried women placed a high premium
on finding a spouse with a steady job
only 48 of men shared this view one
study found that marriages where the
wife out earned her husband were 50 more
likely to end in divorce another study
also found that men who were not the
primary breadwinner were more likely to
use erectile dysfunction meditation uh
medication meditation uh relative to
relative to men that were i've also seen
statistics around women who are the
primary breadwinner faking more orgasms
reporting less sexual satisfaction so
for all that it's well and good offering
women the opportunity to try and have it
all to be able to do both it seems like
a zero-sum game at least in part or
closer to zero sum game than a positive
sum game
and this is the this is the the
fundamental issue of trade-offs right
you having it all
is not possible everybody has to make
trade-offs and it seems like
if men help women and that causes a
relationship to be more likely to fail
what are we doing here
if men help women do what do you have a
job to focus more on to their career if
they push them across but in so doing
they basically hamstring themselves to
be on a ticking time clock i've also
seen william costello was telling me
that hypergamy there is a little bit of
data showing that hypergamy is reducing
but it's reducing directly
proportionally in line with female
infidelity but not male infidelity
so
yeah wild
yeah
so
so yes this is a conundrum but you know
so many women you know
so
uh
it's it's it's a hard subject to talk
about because i personally
am a huge proponent proponent of women
building wealth because i think it
equals freedom
uh and
that brings a lot of value with it but
yes it does disturb partnerships there's
no way around that so you're right as
women start earning more marital
satisfaction goes down for men and for
women and you know as
there's there's you know i that's really
interesting the data that you were
talking about i know that we had dug
some up for a paper that we were writing
looking at you know as as women move up
the corporate ladder they're more likely
to be come divorced but that's not true
for men if women win political office uh
they're more likely to get divorced than
the women counterparts who lost their
political office
the more women gain status the more
discord happens in their their marriage
and you know i guess that's that's no
big shocker so like how do you get
around that i mean there are many
relationships out there you'd have to be
like
you know you are
you know the
you know michael dell and you help you
know your wife get she's never going to
be at your level so that's not going to
be a problem it's more of like the sort
of like
you know mid-manager level
you know problems when we're you know
like when you have dual
couples that are you know
you know fighting for that's another
thing fighting for time for your career
yeah well i mean here's another element
why do you think it is that women who
earn a lot of money want a man that
earns a lot of money
uh well so i think that's um you know
also a vestige that's very deeply
seated in her
brain and it and it's hard to
it's hard to eradicate that it almost
like you feel like so much power and
value and being able to you know
attract a man of high status also you
have more in common with that person or
maybe you feel like you do or you feel
like you're more attracted to those kind
of men that doesn't go away
uh as a woman
gains higher status and so you know i
know that um
you know there's
folks that say oh well you know women
are gonna have to start going for you
know blue collar guys who just make a
lot of money and they're a plumber and
um and you know again we have that part
of our brain that might be able to do a
couple of you know gymnastics mental
gymnastics and and come to
to that but it's it's it's really
difficult so that you know wanting
someone who is your counterpart or even
higher than you in status
it's it's pretty down deep inside of our
brain and so you know can we can we
overcome it yeah how do we overcome it
i
i think like the most highest status men
in the world are gonna have to start
doing laundry and we're gonna have to
see it you know and they're gonna have
to start taking parental leave to take
care of their kids and we're gonna have
to see it you know so what you're what
you're saying here is that the men that
hold the highest status that cascade
down from there the social norms that
other men follow that tell us what is
highly regarded what is held in high
status
need to be setting an example
by doing things which affords men who
are
struggling to compete with their female
mates earning education status potential
it allows them to be put on a pedestal
for doing things that would have been
typically more domestic right
so i think
that may be a difficult ask yeah i think
it's a
i think it is
um
i think because you you're saying it's a
difficult ass because men aren't going
to want to do that stuff especially the
men at the top yeah and if it is it's a
stage like george clooney's doing
laundry today um you know for a photo
people magazine
um and then i don't know maybe there
needs to be that maybe companies can
mandate their leadership team take
family leave
so there are things that can happen and
yeah i don't think men are going to be
lining up for
you know laundry or whatever
but
i could see that changing
you know women yeah so it's like i i
can't get george clooney but i want
someone who's like him and he's the guy
who does laundry so that's acceptable
and i'm still attracted to my mate who
is going around doing this in my house
we are up against a serious god's eye
coordination problem here aren't we i
think i mean this is one of the
fascinating things
i i i very much enjoy talking about the
dynamics that underpin it i very much
get switched off when i hear
people on the internet a lot of the time
on twitter saying that this is the way
that the world should be and
the reason that i do that is it sounds a
lot like hypocrisy to me because
revealed and stated preferences are
clashing up against each other
face-first here you know the only reason
that tom holland and zendaya made
headlines apart from the fact that
they're both superstars was that she's
taller than him and that was being used
as look you see short men shouldn't be
so self-conscious about their height you
go do you really think that short men
aren't trying to date zendaya like do
you really think that that's the case so
my point being that
when stated preferences get put out on
the internet they sound great in
egalitarian when revealed preferences
come through everybody's still trying to
chase down i mean i'm sure that you've
seen this leonardo dicaprio thing yeah
yeah yeah right so funny
unbelievable right okay so i know that
you've done you've done research on bad
boys women why are women still chasing
bad boys leonardo dicaprio
uh john mayer
and do women's preferences for bad boys
change over time as they age
oh that's interesting um
so
yeah when we say bad boy i mean that's
like a you know a moniker that we use i
guess to mean somebody who's really
socially dominant and you know
charismatic and you know i always use
george clooney but i know he's like so
dated because anybody i mentioned that
too is like he's really old now yeah any
students like oh he's old well who can i
use i don't know but you know just sort
of like you know thinking about the
classic
you know um rebel without a cause
type of a guy i mean
like think about all the movies and the
songs and the metal bands i mean these
guys are sexy but more than that it's
there's something evolutionarily put in
there as well something evolutionarily
there so
social dominance
was it bought you a lot over the course
of human history and it bought you a lot
of status and if you were a risk taker
you know that bought you a lot you were
really good at protection you were
really good at finding so all of these
are sort of like proxies for like
estimations about how good you might be
in terms of um yes getting resources but
yes and yes your status
but
you know
if we talk about our most anciently
evolved attraction systems it's indirect
genetic benefits
and then when what does that mean that
means genes so
if
you know this is this is the top dog guy
and if i have a
you know i'm attracted to him so we
don't have to think if i have a baby
with him my son's going to have those
jeans like we don't really think yeah
but it's just like that increased
attraction like you are just
um programmed to optimize mate choice
and so that's why we find these like
devil may care
guys so now you know is it is it as
valuable in our you know nowadays i
don't know that's a question maybe we
can talk about but it certainly was
ancestrally these are the guys that were
the first ones up on the hill when we
needed to conquer you know another group
but you know so
you know and then but these guys also
don't make the best husbands in the
world
so often women do have to make a
trade-off between you know different
features in a mate that they value
didn't you find out though that women
looked at bad boys
and that they did think
that they would be better
fathers
yeah for them so
yes so
uh
yeah this is one of my favorite studies
i ever ran because we hired an actor and
he was just amazing because he played
both roles he
pretended he was a twin right yeah yeah
he was like
superb at it and we had a hollywood
screenwriter write a bad boy and we had
a hollywood screener a writer a kind of
a nerd a shy standoffish kind of guy
and
yeah you know
when women were imagining so they were
talking to this guy thinking he was a
prospective partner for them like they
might date
and so then when they're like thinking
about themselves with this guy
they did when they were ovulating report
that oh my god i could totally see him
doing my dishes and he'd probably be a
great dad and so it's like these you
know rose-colored glasses came on
especially when it came to partner
skills so it wasn't like oh yeah when
i'm ovulating i think he's going to be a
better guitar player or a better piano
player or nicer to his grandma it was
like no he's going to be a better
partner for me
overall
so yeah so but that's that's sorry
outside of ovulating were these women or
what other women not seeing the bad boy
as the preferential
carer would they have seen the nerd
so
i'd have to i don't remember these so so
it's like the stable guy we always kind
of want those qualities at some level
but um
it was it wasn't like they were totally
turned off by the bad guy or bad boy guy
at you know at lower fertility
um well that's that's the dangerous
element right like this is where um some
of the redder corners of the internet
find
kernels of truth that they can latch on
to that right you know you use uh
charisma and social dominance as a proxy
for confidence competence
conscientiousness industriousness all of
the things you know status resources
blah blah blah
and
it's pretty robust which
is a little bit of a difficult one
because again revealed in stated
preferences i want the
but then i suppose these are stated
preferences as well right so they are
but we also we also videotaped their
behaviors and
you know non-verbal verbal they were
acting very differently you know with
these flicking the hair and the playing
hair and you know and so in the same
session they met with these set of twins
you know one twin was nerdy one twin was
a bad boy
and that guy asked the same question so
for example like the nerdy guy would be
like so what do you what are you doing
for the holiday oh me and my boyfriend
are gonna go to las vegas then the bad
boy asks her what she's going to be
doing for the holidays she said me and
my friend are going to be going to las
vegas so little tiny changes oh my god
that happened are
revealed because
you know these this is this is an
indicator that there is increased
attraction to this you know bad boy type
of guy same man so you can't say like oh
one is so like you know dreamy and the
other one's so ugly no same guy
controlled it's his behavior came across
as like yeah you know go out with me
don't i don't care whatever but if you
do go out with me like you will start
writing with your left hand if you're
right-handed that's how great it's going
to be you know
um
so all right that's
that's what's going on uh internally
what about
the local ecology how do sex ratios
change women's desire for career versus
family
so
i looked into this a little bit and it
was really stemming from like why was i
such a nerd in
high school like why do women
you know
i just wanted to understand what makes
women like into sort of lean in
type of woman versus a lean out type of
a woman and you know
i i wondered if if
first of all i wondered if how they did
you know on the mating market when they
first um you know hit puberty had
anything to do with it but then i found
that you know one thing that disrupts
the mating market is is sex ratio so
um
when
when there's no men around women become
more competitive because there's just
you know fewer
partners out there
for them
we know that and one of the things that
we looked into was do women prefer which
is their ambition change so they were
becoming more ambitious and they were
desiring career over family so that
trade-off when we led women to believe
that this is a college campus that there
was just a
like
like so many more women around than
there were men then they were like i
want a career
and
um you know and not just any career i
want to be you know on the leadership
team of a corporate you know company and
so it's not but that's not just you know
so we say that's stated preference i
guess but we found this um in
demographic data too
um which it's not an experiment so we
can you know when there's no when there
are fewer men around there's more women
that are pilots and surgeons and lawyers
and so that's great news because women
can and want to do this job but it has a
lot to do with like what's going on in
the mating environment
um is there an argument is there an
argument to be made as well that there's
nothing else for them to spend their
time on with the men so i might as well
invest it into that but if the right man
came along then the career might stop
yeah so the opposite of that is when
they were just sort of like
you know
when there were a lot of men around and
there were a lot of great options then
women wanted family
so it's it's it's sort of like you know
your brain is kind of figuring out like
what's going on in my environment is it
is it is it good for you know mating is
it not good and then sort of directing
your behavior
um accordingly and if it's if it's a
good time to strike
and you can get a really high quality
partner which is sort of the the
opposite was we were leading them to
believe that there were a lot of men on
campus then it was like oh i'm going to
i'm going to do family
and so we started calling it plan a and
plan b
um and i'm a plan so it's like and
there's nothing wrong with plan b i'm a
plan b person because i was a nerd in
high school because i couldn't get out
of my
um own head about being a nerd ever
um you know i was just like career
career career career career i mean and
then i went back to my high school
reunion and they're like oh okay oh yeah
christina you were always in the library
but they're like oh who are you you know
they didn't remember me because i was
always
i guess in the library
um
but
yeah so i think that it changes
with the mating market
the wildest thing that i see there is
the second ratio hypothesis when i first
learned about that it blew my mind then
i learned about the changes in mating
strategy so short-term versus long-term
and women the gatekeepers to sex they're
the supply in men of the demand so it's
kind of them i guess that play by the
rules that are going on men don't really
have the rules they're just go go go
but what you've got going on here is
behavior influenced by the mating market
the local mating market
which isn't necessarily to do with
mating
you would say your career as a woman
is one of the things that is as a man
you might be able to make the the
argument that your career choice is very
much influenced by the mating market
that you want to i would imagine that
the reverse may be true that men also
become more competitive for particular
types of jobs in a place where there are
uh fewer fewer women but the fact that
you are influencing behavior which
doesn't directly relate to your mate
value really yeah
yeah
based on something which is to do with
mating dynamics is
absolutely insane yeah well i think it's
like we're so hardwired to figure out
what's going on in the mating market
that it just it trickles down to
whatever the tools are to get your own
resources like well i might have to i
might have to go out and you know figure
out how i'm going to do this on my own
um or you know
it and we really don't know and it could
be like well i'm going to go into these
high-paying careers because maybe
there's more men there
but
but oh my god that is such an unpopular
theory to go for the reason that women
want high paying careers is because
there's maybe some hot men in there
yeah i mean
so
so
no but
you know we don't know but so the
leading
uh
theory is is that you know uh you got to
take care of yourself yeah and
um maximize independence yeah and and
you know running a household is really
hard and it just is so much
i it is so much easier when there's
another adult around when you have
someone that you know you can pool
resources with it's easier and it's more
difficult because then you got to manage
you know the relationship but i think
that you know a lot of women especially
young women that is you know you know
that is really important like is am i
gonna find you know my soulmate my ideal
mate right now or is that gonna be
really hard for me because if it is then
i've got to figure out in this world
with these tools how i'm going to
support myself
you did a ton of work around buying
behavior what consumer behavior what
women buy and why they do it and stuff
if someone has never thought about i
don't even know what you call it
gendered buying uh if someone's never
considered this like why do women buy
the things that they buy what what is
there to know here
well that's a really
broad question and so
my
first
i guess
series of studies that i looked at
women's consumer behavior was looking at
their consumer behavior across the
ovulatory cycle because um you know
these fundamental motives that we have
um in life um mating
get status
have kids
protect yourself from disease these are
all fundamental
motives and
when women are ovulating
like we were talking about before
they're they're really interested their
sexual desire goes up so they you know
they they want to look i thought well if
their sexual desires is up maybe they
want to look sexier
and so the first study i ever did was
looking at women's clothing preferences
across the ovulatory cycle and we would
find these really strong differences in
what women would choose to wear for
themselves out of their own closet or
even just imagined in their head or when
they were shopping on a website
it was it was just you know it was it
was sexier they wanted to look more
fashionable so they were spending you
know more money and and choosing more
items that were you know sexy
uh when they were ovulating and and less
so when they were weren't
um but all of these you know
i always call them tools because that's
what products are as tools so it's like
what does evolutionary psychology have
to do with what we
buy
and it's like there's so many products
out there most products out there
serve these fundamental motives that
have deep evolutionary roots so even
lipstick you know certainly wasn't
around
uh 10 000 years ago but the the
motivation
to buy
is still a motivation that was around a
long time ago and influenced by all of
the factors that we're talking about
like
who am i going to the club with who's in
my social network you know
how you know how do things look for me
am i married am i single you know all
these things and you know then we can
you know we can predict how that might
change uh women's consumption um but
yeah so you know we got clothes we've
got you know all these different
cosmetic procedures and skin care and
women everything do women wear different
types of makeup
throughout their ovulatory side yeah
they wear more makeup
when they're ovulating um and i think
that's just uh and i didn't run this
study but my colleagues did and i think
that's just a product of wanting to you
know just feeling sexier wanting to be
more attractive you know wanting to
optimize mate choice you know and and
you know being more focused on
on that is that mediated by whether
they're in a relationship or not do
single women do this more than married
women that's a good question and i don't
know the answer to that because i don't
remember from their data but a lot of
these differences we don't um i know
that i talked about a really big one
with the politics but for consumer
consumption i don't find differences
even with um between heterosexual and
lesbian women
they still
are showing you know the greater
interest in
um you know products that
will make them look
more attractive what are the fundamental
what's the fundamental driving force of
women's purchases then is it
signals of youth and fertility because
there's like
bags and and heels and yeah other things
that i don't know what women buy
whatever that is
yeah so for many years that was sort of
the and i guess it still is is women's
luxury consumption because women spend
you know
women spend more on luxury than men do
uh with the bags and the you know the
purses and you know the clothes and
um it's so
um you know it was a really it was a
conundrum because you know men don't
know the difference between you know uh
louis louvre or a louboutin you know
they don't know
louboutin from a jc penny
at the moment
[Laughter]
um so what are
you know so why are women you know
buying luxury if it's not for men you
know who might it be for
and so
the original sort of
past few papers that we had was about
must be for intersexual competition
purposes with other women so they're
signaling to other women signaling
something um to other women and it it
might just be their status to sort of
you know
show you know don't mess with me you
know like all the spare resources i've
got i could wreck you yeah i mean like
an or you know investment from a partner
um but oh so sorry could that be a sign
of
this is how much my partner's invested
in me
therefore you don't want to try and take
him away from me because he's just spent
three grand on this handbag something
like that yes it could be that
could be that
um and it could just be
you know
luxury is associated with high status
and
status buys you so much in life that we
just you know kind of have you know we
just go gaga for trying to get as much
you know status and accolades and people
clapping for us and you know that we can
because it used to
be so valuable it was sometimes the
difference between life and death
and so
buying luxury
um you know the motivation might just be
to associate with those people or
associate yourself with the kind of
people who can buy these things and
that's why you know they i think all
these luxury brands have like key chains
and little like cheaper things that all
the rest of us can buy to just feel a
little bit like we're part of that group
we're often told about the importance of
dominance hierarchy and status for men
state the seeking men high status men
are the most attractive ones
what does status mean or how does it
manifest for
women so i don't know that it's
different for women than it is uh for
men um although
you know yeah i mean i think it's i
think it's
you know the same in terms of you know a
dominance
hierarchy i think it's still like i'm
you know i have this i won
um
and it works the same way
i always consider it you know sort of
the same in men and women and maybe it
manifests differently
and it does in terms of you know maybe
the consumer products that are attracted
to but um you know
for
or or career career striving um
you know we did manipulate the mating
market and you know when men were gone
women were like oh yeah i'm gonna be a
cert you know it's like so it's like so
when you kind of take men off the table
then women are free to express these you
know preferences for following passions
or jobs or you know whatever
um you know and i find that really
interesting because men and women really
are
have these curiosities that feed into
career preferences and then women learn
that there's a trade-off to be made
yes given the fact
just going back to what we talked about
before given the fact that um the local
ecology the sex ratio between men and
women heavily mediates what women want
to do with regards to their career
versus family how do you work out which
one's the set point
you mean which one is sort of the base
yeah which one which one's the the
natural then you've got naturalistic
fallacy which one's the desirable what
they will then what do you mean in terms
of desirable what are you optimizing for
whose value judgment do you put on top
of it my point being if it can be
mediated so heavily by the local men
like
we don't know whether or not women that
are going to go to their graves are
going to be more satisfied with a lot of
houses and no kids or the ones that have
lots of kids but are scraping around for
money or all of this stuff like it's i'm
just trying to work out what it is
where we work out what it is that women
want
without the external influence of the
environment is that is that even
something that's possible to do yeah
i
i
i don't know i mean that's a really
tricky question i think they're you know
emerging
is more variance in things like we were
talking about before like women wanting
to have kids do they
you know do they end up having kids do
they not do they go into high paying
careers um you know do they not uh
so i don't i don't know i guess my
answer is like you know marriage is set
up it highly benefits men and you know
you know i don't want to paint the
picture of women being doomed but a lot
of women do come up against this you
know trade-off and you know some women
are totally happy just moving forward
and being focused on their careers and
some women that's not for them they're
going to be you know more aligned with
you know staying home and building a
family and that gives them that sort of
sense of value and accomplishment just
like it would be if
for another woman working up the
leadership team ladder
so i think there's a lot of individual
you know differences there i guess the
commonality is that
most women run up against this you know
having to figure out the trade-off yes
yes that's a that's a good point the
fact that the trade-off is there no
matter what um for women and given the
fact that there are fewer femme cells
than in cells
most women at some point will probably
have the option to make this decision
but this is as i was
reading through some of your work i kept
on thinking about uh barry schwartz is
the paradox of choice
oh yes yeah because that has to play a
huge part of this for the people that
don't know barry schwartz uses this
really great example in this legendary
ted talk where he talks about genes and
he says like in the 70s there was one
type of genes and you'd go in and it
would be what's your way size and you'd
walk out with a pair of blue jeans and
now you go in and it's do you want
skinny or boot cut do you want the stone
wash do you want the black do you want
the stretch do you want the whatever and
we would think that being utilitarian
rational beings giving people more
options would mean that they would be
able to refine their choice more
accurately to what they genuinely want
versus what the market can offer them
but it turns out quite the opposite that
this decision fatigue
existential dread of denim choice that
we're faced with causes us to regret the
decisions that we didn't make and to
vacillate about the decisions that we
should make a lot more and
this is i mean the genie's not going
back in the bottle with regards to women
being in the workplace educational
attainment equality and so on and so
forth but there is an interesting
question to be asked around whether or
not this overall
makes for a happier existence the
question basically is is ignorance bliss
and no one's running no politicians
running on the on the policy of women
have you ever considered regressing back
to the 1940s because it's very i i know
that you might not be happy about the
lack of money but it would make your
dating options a lot easier
yeah yeah so there are many negatives
about you know turning the clock back to
the 1940s but there would be a lot of
decisions that were made for you that
you wouldn't have to
you know worry about um i strongly
believe that the abundance of choice has
made us
so much
more miserable than we ever have been in
fact you know i have a paper called
serendipity because um we don't have a
lot of that anymore
um because of the sort of saturation of
choice
uh
because of the endless choices that we
find in
you know from consumer products to mates
it's just you know like you were saying
you know even within category of
consumer products there's just so many
you know different kinds of pairs of
you know blue jeans that we could have
we could we could choose and then you
know the opportunity cost is so salient
and you know we're choosing wrong and
then you know we
defer choice all together or you know
other things and we've actually looked
at so you think about dating apps right
where you know our brain is getting the
signal that there's just so many you
know people out there that could
possibly be our partners
and we
and and even though they're in our phone
or on our tv or wherever our brain is at
some level categorizing these people as
part of our group
and you know because no one came into
your living space thousands of years ago
who wasn't a part of your group so it's
potential
and
so
you know but you know so there's just so
many people out there and so you you
choose one you go on a date and
you know you're thinking about that
person
versus all of the other ones that could
be better out there that you have really
easy access to
and it does something to satisfaction
so we we tried our best so i have a
paper on serendipity and it's all about
consumer products but we did try to do
this with mating where you know we gave
people
um you know a choice of a partner
and they picked a partner and then they
kept seeing that partner over and over
again so it was like it was like we were
doing like a saturation
um
and we do this with consumer products
all the time or eventually you're like
oh my god i love this cookie and you're
like i can't eat that cookie again um
and so like eventually like exposure
decreases attraction like the more and
more you're seeing this person sexual
attraction did you see that most recent
paper that came out about women's
decline in uh sexual attraction
occurring more quickly than men's i did
i did and so and my female colleagues
were like yes so we knew this and now
they're we already knew this but now
there's some data behind it and then the
men were like there's got to be
moderators
yeah probably
but um but you know i think you know
overall there's a decline in in marital
satisfaction that just happens for men
and women over time
as it does with like anything you you
know see again and again again it's not
going to have that you know sort of like
magical um spark but we were we we had
two conditions one in which it was set
up like a dating app where they were
looking at a bunch of pictures chose one
person to talk to
and then we had another condition where
they were just like it was like it was
like what now netflix has because they
caught on to it like random assignment
here's your mate and then those people
were more satisfied over time even doing
the different exposures than the ones
that chose from a selection of mates and
we think it was because their brain was
on
wow there's so many others out there
like i chose this like you have endless
supplies of candy you can only choose
one kind and then you finally make your
choice it's really hard to choose
and
then it's okay but i wonder what that
one other one would have been like you
know we're thinking about that whereas
if you just sort of randomly come upon
something
you like it more it's like you know when
a song comes randomly on the radio you
like it more than if it was something
you chose from your playlist that's
interesting okay so i i understand why
the serendipity thing gets lost i think
when it comes to me i'm the sort of
person who when i was a teenager would
obsess over the all the different
features of all the nokia phones and i'd
think about the one i was going to
upgrade to for six months beforehand and
stuff like that and there's still
there's still elements of that in me
one of the solutions that i've found to
kind of get around that is to place an
arbitrary constraint on how long i have
to make the decision
so if i've got to choose between three
different hotels i'm going to rome i'm
taking my mum to rome in a couple of
weeks time and i was just like look
you've got 10 minutes you have 10
minutes to choose and once the 10
minutes is up like you that's it you're
done so it actually did help a little
bit and i i don't i don't care i don't
think about the other hotels i could
have what i should have got i've got you
know three or four different tabs open
that one that one that one best location
we'll go for that one i'm done
um but yeah i mean the fact that we're
having i'm having to create this
weird
temporal mind prison in a desperate
attempt to not feel
choice anxiety is
is a strange one all right so thinking
about um one of the common
tropes or headlines that you see online
with regards to women
purchasing decisions and stuff like that
how right do you think it is to lay
women's desire for focus on beauty and
dieting and signals of fitness at the
feet of capitalism
how
what do what do i think about making you
know
how right is it to throw those yeah to
because i mean you know a lot of the
time the accusation is these
big big wigs sat in offices in new york
city designing marketing campaigns that
do the whatever um
how right is that to to laid at the feet
of capitalism well i don't know i don't
know if it's it's right or wrong i mean
i'm meant
an evolutionary psychologist but i'm in
the marketing department um
so
i i don't know it can be totally off
base at times it
totally depends and i think it changes
with you know how society is changing
certainly things are changing
rapidly now with
especially in the beauty industry it's
like you know all more inclusive it's
not exactly what it was before
you know victoria's secret took huge you
know amount of you know online
punishment for
their not keeping up with the times and
being more inclusive um and you know
they eventually had to you know get with
it or die completely
um and so that's really you know new um
but you know i it's i i don't know is it
right or wrong i i guess you know
consumers you know can you know
be smart and make up their own minds and
realize that there is always going to be
someone behind the curtain that's trying
to manipulate your
preferences and your purchasing i mean
that's you know sort of what you know
the advertising and marketing industry
is
is all about um
you know if that's what you're getting
at like it's really hard to say it's
right or wrong um but it's gonna
continue uh because businesses are
always in invested in in you know
strengthening the bottom line
um even if it means by you know creating
an illusion for you in order for you to
buy the product
looking at the different consumer
purchases of
men and women were there any surprising
purchases which were actually effective
at attracting a mate
oh that's a really good question
um and we didn't measure the end result
like did this attract
a partner because you you you bought
this i think some of my colleagues
looked at like men looking at women with
you know expensive handbags and
you know and that's where and found that
when we're like the men were like wow
she's gonna be a lot of maintenance um
so we didn't find that men were more
attracted to women with you know
designer handbags than they were with
women with you know
you know no handbag or lower class
handbag or whatever
um
but um but i've never really looked at
you know outcomes of
you know consumer purchases on dating
but you know i think this goes for men
and women you know people who pay
attention to their attractiveness and
you know try to clean themselves up and
just be you know attentive to general
overall you know hygiene that that is
going to be very helpful those products
in you know in attracting mates and then
um
you know for but again the jury's still
out on women's luxury purchases like
does that help i don't know maybe
aligning with you know high status
groups uh does buy you something um but
for men you know having these you know
having a car that's you know like uh
was a maserati or something you know
that helps
you know so because women are more
interested in status when it comes to um
you know their their partners than men
are there's an interesting study that i
saw on tinder to do with right swipes on
a guy exactly the same guy but they
replaced the nissan altima with a lexus
and the guy it was like a significant
increase in the number of right swipes
but that being said there's also a
significant number of increases in right
swipes if you've got a dog versus if
you've got a cat a cat is actually below
the control and the dog is significantly
above so what you want is a dog in a
lexus basically and that's
presumably maximum right swipes yeah
that's really interesting yeah because a
dog is masculine and a cat is
feminine that's how the man was
interpreted yeah also that
i think women understand the fact that
the dog requires care that the cat is
basically an independent creature
yes he has to be more paternal he has to
be able to be conscientious industrious
reliable orderly how would you this dog
would be dead whereas the cat can be you
can be the worst cat owner in history
and the cat will still be fine right
yeah that's really interesting yeah so
putting a man in a situation where he's
so you know it's like think about gender
differences and attraction for a woman
walking on an airplane holding a baby
versus a man walking on an airplane
holding a baby like if you can do this
real live experiment and i've seen it
where oh
everybody's happy that a man is carrying
a baby the woman's carrying the baby
everyone's fearful that he's going to
cry
not another one next to me and i think
you know so i think that it's like women
talk so this is another wanting to have
it all we all want to have it all in our
mate we want our mate to be socially
dominant and he's going to charge up
that hill and be you know risk taker and
you know fight everyone but us and then
at home you know be you know really nice
and agreeable
so i had a
logan yuri who is hinge's director of
relationship science on the show oh okay
and obviously she's got access to just
so much fascinating data she calls them
an era of maximizers these people who
want to maximize absolutely every
different statistic that they can have
with their partner
and when you've got um mate match it's
it's strange right so you have
assortative mating but you also have
this everyone wants to just pitch
themselves a little bit a little bit
beyond where it is that they are um and
when you combine that with the fact that
one of the in fact it might be the
single biggest predictor of extramarital
sex is pre-marital sex or extramarital
partners is pre-marital partners
basically the more people that you've
slept with before your partner the more
likely you are that you're going to
cheat
oh interesting yeah so
when you combine all of that together
with a global sexual marketplace that is
the most frictionless way to just browse
all of the different types of genes
that you would
be potentially prepared to try on yeah
yeah it's fascinating to think about
like how that is operating inside a
brain that's used to coming in contact
with 50 to 100 people and that's it and
then you die you know and now it's whoa
it's blowing your mind will will's
costello's got this uh theory around um
to do with his in-cell research
where he said that you can achieve in a
single day more rejection than a man
would have achieved in his entire
lifetime yeah and but the rejection
hurts less but it hurts less in the
moment but what's the cue that it's
telling you is there something that it's
keeping track there's a little ticker
one other thing i remember reading this
ages ago that was an interesting uh
way to frame married couples purchasing
choices
so
when you have a married couple
you are pulling together your resources
into a single bank right a single a
single block of cash and then from that
each person draws out
money
but the men
and what they spend their money on and
the women and what they spend their
money on seems to continue to be signals
of fitness
outside of the relationship the man is
buying the watch which signals status
prestige the fast car which means that
if he was on tinder he would get more
right swipes he'll certainly get more
turn looks from the women that are on
the street the woman is still signaling
fertility and youth maybe she's getting
cosmetic procedures maybe she's buying
expensive makeup and expensive beauty
products and stuff like that
is there not something really like kind
of hilarious about the fact that both of
these people have pulled their resources
together to then separately spend them
on things that signal make fitness
yeah that's really interesting um then
not surprising i guess um you know uh
these are so we have these like you know
monogamous marriages but then it's not
our mating system so it never goes away
like you don't get married and then
you're you know completely dead from all
these other
you know the motivations uh that we have
um for people externally um in in the in
the work that i did with um having you
know a highly attractive bad boy type of
guy
um and looking at women's choices of you
know products across the cycle like i
said we didn't find differences between
heterosexual and homosexual women
homosexual women were still making
themselves more attractive when they
were preparing to meet the bad boy no
way yes and so what do you think is
going on there
it's just so deep-seated that even
someone who isn't sexually attracted to
them with their current like sexual
identities
that's what i thought i thought
initially i was like well maybe it's
because we just as women didn't have a
lot of control over mate choice we had
some control right but not you know as
much as we have right now so maybe it's
that
but also
what occurred to me is that you know
attractive people
tend to be the people who are higher
status and get you know favored
and you know get the better jobs and get
the better resources and so maybe it's
just a cute uh to not you know to look
good so that this person likes you
you're just currying favor through halo
effect right okay yeah so it's like so
it could it could be that although like
i said we didn't find that you know
and these were ovulated because they
were ovulating uh
homosexual women i should say
um so that's kind of it it was that
i thought that it was just like this is
the hormonal profile but it's not
directed to the target
you would think
um but it could still just have value if
you know you're going to be
meeting this person and so
and i know that's not exactly what you
meant by the pooling of the resources
and then people still spend it on uh you
know those things but you know hey you
know aligning yourself with with what's
externally valued still
reaps for words so i you know i
it we're not we are no longer
stopping trying to attract our partner
as well
you know that's true it's it's whatever
you would say like intra marriage like
yeah i guess that should have been my
first thought like yeah you know you
still have to keep her
the other half happy yeah and attracted
and presumably the cues it's not like
the cues change that much yeah men's
testosterone might go down a little bit
women are a little bit more aggressive
if they smell the newborn baby's head
but fundamentally we're still running on
the same sort of programming right yeah
how do you i keep on having this
conversation with people um because i'm
touching on a lot of evolutionary
psychology at the moment because i'm
fascinated by it and it's not going to
stop so sorry but a lot of people that
listen to a good bit of the stuff that
comes out from the show
mention that the more that they learn
about evolutionary psychology the less
that they can see people
as people
they don't see them as the architect of
their own actions they see them with
less agency um
how have you
integrated your
increasing understanding of the motives
that drive human behavior
without losing your mind
well
because we have a prefrontal cortex and
i love it and i hate it at the same time
so it means that you know i
you know the the hormones don't take
over completely like they do in other
animals where it's just you become a
robot and it's like you switch you know
um and i'm seeing that in my my female
dog i think
she was gonna get spayed i i i put it
off because she's in the middle of her
cycle and she just totally changes all
her behavior and she's just like looking
for her you know just her babies it's
just so crazy and male 1 did she have a
phantom pregnancy
um no no she didn't she just is a puppy
and
she went into heat um before i thought
she was going to and i want to let her
complete the cycle before i
spay her
but i see the change in her behavior and
it's just like
really automatic like almost like an
automatron like you know she is one
thing the next and the other day she's
just like can't wait to find a partner
you know and that's all she's
thinking about is who can i what male
dog can i get in front of you know and
so as a basic level it's that now humans
are
so much more complex um than that but we
still like i was saying before we still
have sort of the the parts of our brains
that we share with all mammals even you
know all organisms if you go even deeper
you know reproduce so we like sex we
like to rest we like to eat you know all
those kind of things and then you know
what makes us human is the part of our
brain that you know we can
intellectualize all this stuff and
um i actually find it so much more
helpful to my well-being to think about
this um you know research shows if you
know the game is rigged in some way and
you know how it's rigged and how it's
set up it just makes how you get through
the day a lot easier it certainly does
um for me and you know it's not to say
that we're
you know we're sort of
animatronic you know
like animals you know but but we kind of
need the blueprint and to be like oh
you know to sort of find these
workarounds i feel this way because of
this
um
you know because i'm just feeling really
competitive with this person right now
and that's probably because it's
something i'm lacking in my life or you
know we can do the sort of backtrack of
you know when we when we don't
feel our best or you know so i don't see
it as such a sad story as
maybe others do
i don't either i mean for me
the only way that you can transcend your
programming is by understanding it right
absolutely and that's the first step
right and so
you know as much as i understood like
the pushback that i got for the one
paper that i had on politics
you know my approach has always been
like let's try to understand things and
so
you know yeah replicate it see if this
is even a thing for sure but um but
don't say that it just you know can't be
because
let's just not look at this anymore it
certainly scared me away
from looking at it anymore but um you
know i still think that we're in the
business of you know building knowledge
and it has to be across the board
knowledge not like knowledge that's
convenient and
some that you know is feel good it's
just this is life and
i want to understand my life just like
we understand the lives of other
organisms and we don't you know put
you know our opinions on them
um
yeah that's the way that i feel i've i
robert writes the moral animal was the
first thing i ever read about
evolutionary psychology and as i was
reading through that it was kind of like
i don't know
veils falling in front of my eyes and
every single time that i learned
something else and okay well
the amount of satisfaction that i get
from understanding why we are the way we
are and the programming that we have
as far as i'm concerned way way
outweighs
any discomfort that i have to deal with
for the fact that it's going to be oh
well like i'm going to have to
understand that the reason he's being
aggressive is because of male parental
uncertainty or whatever it is that is
causing somebody to act the way that
they do yeah
it's i find it beautiful i genuinely do
and the only way that you can transcend
it is by understanding it and being
aware of it so yeah absolutely christina
durante ladies and gentlemen if people
want to keep up to date with the stuff
that you do where should they go
uh they can find me on twitter at
christina durante um i'm also on
instagram at christinaunderscoreduranti
and then christina durante.com
fantastic christina i appreciate you
thank you thank you what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]